we don't give up cuz it's hard we give
up cuz we get discouraged and so we have
to make sure we overcome discouragement
as a creative person as an artist you
have to make sure you tune out
distractions distractions are the enemy
of greatness live your vision and
Mission which was to encourage and
Inspire as many people as possible one
person at a time and that is what drove
me then and it's what drives me to this
day John Gordon welcome back to the th
media podcast
man in episode one you dropped a lot of
tips about content creation strategies
um and it was such a great episode
talked about the power of why every
content creator and entrepreneur should
consider writing a book but one of the
most prevalent things we are facing
right now in the world is really a
mental health crisis especially P post
pandemic there's so much negativity in
the world there's a lot of gravitational
forces pulling us down that can lead us
to getting discouraged and one of the
biggest challenges for any kind of
entrepreneur content creator person that
wants to package which they know in a
book anybody that's trying to do
anything is going to experience the
resistance they're going to experience
perhaps slow growth they're going to
experience the months or even years
Before the Breakthrough before seeing
all that hard work paying off so I'm so
grateful you're here to help us with
really overcoming discouragement and you
just wrote a new book the one truth
about elevating your mind unlocking your
power and healing your soul and even
this idea of us being able to be in
negative mindsets or even positive
mindsets and I'm excited to unpack this
and so uh John for those that are just
meeting you you've written a lot of
books but what is the story behind the
one truth and this most recent message
you've shared with the world I feel like
every book I've written and the work
I've done over the years has led me to
this moment to write this book the one
truth because so many are struggling
with negativity with fear with stress
they're worrying all the time and here's
the deal we are not meant to go through
life feeling sad discouraged fearful
insecure worried and chronically stress
all the time I believe so many people
have been feeling that way we've almost
normalized it and so now we accept it as
normal but it really isn't normal it's
okay and I've been there and I've dealt
with depression I've dealt with anxiety
I've dealt with all of it so I have no
judgment when I say that what I'm saying
is it's not meant to be our normal State
we are meant to live life with power
with peace with joy with optimism with
hope with belief with creativity with
excitement and passion about what we're
creating and what we're doing so seeing
so many people struggle it's because
they feel separate they feel
disconnected from themselves from others
a team that is divided that feels
separate is a weak team a team that is
United and connected is a powerful
strong team it's the same way with us
when we feel disconnected isolated alone
fearful anxious we feel very weak but we
feel connected we feel one we feel Joy
we feel power we feel peace and
everything comes down to Oneness and
separateness and this is what the one
truth is all about like when you feel
connected to everyone and everything you
feel that you're most creative when
you're feeling that way when you feeling
sad lonely down depressed you're not
very creative and so this is about how
we Elevate our state of mind we Elevate
the antenna of our brain because your
brain literally is an antenna and we
Elevate that and the more you do you
start to tune into more positive
thoughts you start to tune into more
hope and optimism you tune into this
greater energy that that fuels you and
gives you this power to create As You
Are Meant to create and so this is what
the one truth is all about and I'm so
excited that it's coming out but you
know going backwards you talking about
struggling talking about negativity when
I wrote The Energy Bus it was rejected
by over 30 Publishers and so I was told
my dream is not going to happen I was
told to give up so I had these new
thoughts way back when about positivity
that no one was talking about talking
about positive energy and all these kind
of things and it was very new that
Publishers didn't get it bookstores
didn't get it and yet I was ahead of my
time but I had this book that I thought
would would would make an impact but yet
rejected rejected rejected John your
dream is not going to happen your goal
is not going to happen you just sold
your businesses and you focused on this
and now it looks like you may have to go
get a job it was a terrifying time and a
and a fearful time and a scary time but
I kept believing kept hoping kept
putting it out there and I'll never
forget when John Wally and Sons agreed
to publish the book and so it came out
they published it no bookstores would
carry it now though so now I have my
dream yes I published a book but no
bookstores would carry it and so I went
on a I went on a 28 City Tour paid for
myself from City to City sharing the
message in the book we had five people
one city 10 people in another 20 another
the most people have over 100 people in
De Moine Iowa they thought Jeff Gordon
was coming the race car driver that's
why they showed up and I remember I got
home and didn't know what the future
held but I knew that I gave my best and
I went out there and I was sharing the
message and I was adding value and I was
doing the work and I was putting my
stuff out there but I just had to stay
positive and I was struck with the
belief just do the work show up every
day make a difference add value live
your vision and Mission which was to
encourage and Inspire as many people as
possible one person at a time and that
is what drove me then and it's what
drives me to this day because that book
did not become a bestseller for five
years five years that book has now sold
over three million copies actually I
gotta update my bio it sold over three
million copies and it impacts more
people than ever now than it did years
ago and so I think I'm a great example
for Content creators because I dealt
with so much adversity and rejection and
at times pessimism and at times doubt
and there were moments that I wanted to
give up but your purpose must be greater
than your challenges your mission is
greater than all the forces and all of
the adversity that you face and your
optimism is a competitive advantage and
so the more we stay positive and we
bring forth that optimism and belief in
what we're doing and we know why we're
doing it when you know your why you'll
know the way and you won't let obstacles
get in the way and so the more you just
continue to look forward not backward
what am I creating today what am I doing
today to realize this big picture Vision
that I have I call it telescope
microscope big picture Vision telescope
Zoom Focus actions in in the microscope
and every day I'm doing both on the
journey because if I just focus on on
the microscope and I'm grinding every
day but I lose s of the big picture when
things are not going well I'm GNA give
up and if I have the big picture but I'm
not zoom focusing then I'm just living
in fantasy land I'm Dreaming all the
time but I'm not taking actions so I'm
working hard but I remember my purpose I
remember my vision and that keeps me
going through the tough times and that's
what I've done in the past and even to
this day I continue to remind myself
that of that on a daily basis I think a
lot of people can relate Energy Bus your
3 million copy sold book
today comes out 2006 2007 you write it
you publish it rejected by 20 Publishers
five years until it becomes a bestseller
it sounds a lot like starting a new
YouTube channel feeling rejected over
and over again and potentially months or
even years until there's a breakthrough
moment and even as we build up our
library of videos it takes time for the
videos to break out but you didn't quit
and you shared so many mindset um and
attitudes and actions that we could be
taking in response to adversity in
response to slow growth but one of the
things inside of your new book The One
Truth is the tune framework so you've
created four kind of steps that can
really actually help us if we're
particularly in this moment feeling kind
of you know beat down and we want to
build a stronger mindset to just have
the endurance and resilience to uh build
a personal brand build our online
business reach our goals I want to hear
about the tune framework but I also want
to encourage everybody to either
pre-order pick up a copy of the one
truth of course it'll be linked up in
the show notes but John what is the tune
framework I love sharing this and I
include it in in the new book the one
truth and basically this helps us
Elevate our state of mind see negative
thoughts lower our state of mind
negative thoughts separate us and make
us feel Weak and Powerless so think
about negative thoughts that make you
feel sad and discouraged and down
they're not very positive and they're
not very uplifting and often as we're
going through turbulent times or
challenges or getting rejected or not
finding our audience or not feeling like
our purpose is is being valued or being
shared with the world like we want it to
be or received by the world you can get
down and there are five DS that will
sabotage you five DS doubt Distortion
which are negative thoughts and lies
that will tell you things about yourself
and your future that just aren't true
they'll tell you to give up they'll say
the future is hopeless they'll say you
don't have what it takes they will tell
you these things and they'll make you
want to give up and they will discourage
you that's the third D discourage we
don't give up because it's hard we give
up because we get discouraged and so we
have to make sure we overcome
discouragement fourth the distraction so
often as we're trying to build and
create we get distracted by things that
don't matter and don't help us be our
best as a creative person as an artist
you have to make sure you tune out
distractions distractions are the enemy
of greatness but thoughts will always
come in and distract you life will try
to distract you I've written 28 books
now and I've written these books by
getting up every single day when I'm
writing in December I write books in
December and I get up every morning and
I write first thing I don't look at
social media I don't look at emails if I
do I'm done I can't write I write first
and then once I'm done then I will do
what I want to do next but I write first
I do what matters most I do first things
first and that helps you be successful
and so tune out to distractions and then
finally that 50 is
divide and the root word for the Greek
word of anxious means to separate and
divide so when you feel anxious you feel
divided you feel separate what' I say
negative thoughts separate you they
disconnect you from your purpose from
your creativity from God from your true
power from your passion they separate
you so how do we unite how do we get
back to Oneness if you feel separate so
the whole goal is to get back to Oneness
where you'll find your power peace and
joy we tune into the positive we tune
into I believe the creator of the
universe to become more one right more
one how do we do that trust and Truth is
the is the T trust and truth so tune
stands for trust and truth so we trust
when we feel in doubt every time you
feel in doubt out is this really going
to work is this new video going to make
it is my content good again it's always
good to evaluate but don't don't let it
beat yourself up and don't let it defeat
you but just when those doubts come in
that you don't have what it takes you
ask other people hey do I do I have some
Talent do do you see that I can actually
do some good videos and most often you
can most often everyone has potential
that they can get better they can
improve and so when those doubts come in
keep working keep improving keep trus
trus in as you're doing the work so
that's trust and then truth speak truth
to the lies every time those Lies come
in and the best advice I ever heard is
from Dr James gills he's the only person
on the planet to complete six double
Iron Man triathlons that's a double Iron
Man which means you do an Iron Man a day
later do another one and the last time
he did it he was 59 years old and he was
asked how he did it he said this I've
learned to talk to myself instead of
listen to myself that's the key here
instead of listening to those negative
thoughts that are always coming in talk
to yourself with words of encouragement
words of belief words with hope and
optimism talk to yourself don't listen
to the negative thoughts and when I'm
working with professional athletes and
again they are at the highest level of
their craft I ask them do your negative
thoughts come from you and they're
always like yeah of course they're in my
head but here's the next question if you
believe your negative thoughts come from
you who would ever choose to have a
negative negative thought so when I say
don't listen to yourself it's not really
yourself those negative thoughts are
coming in like a nightmare when you're
having a nightmare in a bad dream are
you choosing those thoughts no they're
always coming in don't believe the lies
that they tell speak truth to the lies
and trust that brings us to you Unite
with love and I'll get to that in a
second Unite with love and neutralize
the negativity so often that negativity
comes in Gandhi said I will not let
anyone walk through my mind with their
dirty feet do not let anyone walk
through your mind with their dirty feet
and don't let any negative thoughts walk
neutralize the negativity on the left
side of a piece of paper you write down
those negative thoughts that often come
in for you on the right side write down
the words of encouragement that you will
say to speak truth to those lies as we
talked about just earlier and write down
those words and then practice that on a
daily basis the more you do the more you
practice this you will neutralize the ne
negativity my wife will often and you
know my wife Sean when those negative
thoughts come in she will say stop and
she will then start speaking words of
encouragement Words of Life the word
encourage means to put courage into and
so when you're encouraging yourself
you're putting encourage into yourself
and when you encourage others you put
encourage into them that brings us to e
elevate your thinking how do we Elevate
our thinking research shows you can't be
stressed and thankful at the same time
so when you appreciate you elevate
you're literally elevating your mind and
your antenna when you practice gratitude
I'm convinced abundance flows into your
life when gratitude flows out of your
heart you want to be more creative
practice gratitude be grateful and
you'll get more things to be grateful
about just try it take a walk of
gratitude every single day you'll be
amazed at how many ideas come to you on
these walks it's essential how do we
Elevate our mind go to bed at success
every night what's the one thing that
went great that day the one thing you're
proud of the one thing that made you
smile don't go to bed thinking of all
the bad things because you'll Replay
that over and over again in your mind
while you're sleeping the subconscious
instead talk about your success the one
great thing what happens you go to bed
at success you wake up at success you're
ready to take on the day rather than
thinking it was a bad day so this is key
elevate your thinking and then back to
unite with the love the greatest most
powerful way to think the most powerful
force in the universe is love Unite with
love fear divides fear separates and it
gives rise to all the negative thoughts
love is the antidote to fear love casts
out fear and so the minute you focus on
love fear dissipates when I was writing
the carpenter people say it's my my Best
Book it's about being a carpenter a
Craftsman in a world of Carpenters it's
about working and being amazing in your
craft excellent in your craft so I I
just love this book but I was stuck when
I was writing it and as I'm stuck I
never had writ his block before but I
had it this time I go to bed can't write
this book I'm struggling I wonder if I'm
ever going to write it and I wake up
with the idea and the thought that love
casts out fear like it makes so much
sense all I gotta do is love the reader
that's what I did when I wrote The
Energy Bus love the process of writing
if you love the process you'll love what
the process produces and love even the
struggles that come my way because
they'll make me stronger so love all of
it the minute I did that I wrote that
book in two and a half weeks of divine
inspiration I wo it into the story where
the main character is trying to build
his business a social media company with
his wife and they struggle with fear and
he's got to learn to then bring love to
the equation the book's about loving
serving and caring the greatest success
principles of all and I wrote that book
out of love and that's what will happen
to you when you focus on love instead of
fear so anytime you start to feel
fearful focus on loving creating loving
the content loving the process of what
you're doing and the manye you do you're
not worried about the outcome now you're
focused on the moment you become one
with the moment we call that the Zone in
sports it's also in the creative process
you get into that zone if you love it
you will create something amazing you'll
create a masterpiece if you don't love
it you'll never be great at it so bring
love to it Unite with love tune trust in
truth Unite with love neutralize in
negativity elevate your thinking you
literally elevate your state of mind I
guarantee people apply this and do it
every day you will be the most creative
you've ever been I will get emails which
is that which is what happens to me
often I get emails all the time saying
I'm doing my best work I just created
this and you'll be saying thank you John
and I'm not taking credit I'm not saying
that in an arrogant way I'm take I'm
saying it because I know it's gonna
impact you in such amazing ways and I
can't wait to hear what you create by
applying the tune methodology I want to
invite you guys to our YouTube 1K
challenge you can join this challenge
for free as we show you how to grow your
first 1,000 subscribers and make your
first $11,000 on YouTube we've had
countless people join us during this 1K
challenge who are now at 1,000
subscribers and past 1,000 subscribers
making money on YouTube and you could be
the next person if you just go to 21k
challenge.com you can sign up for the
very next challenge and we can't wait to
see you guys there this is one of those
episodes to save and repeat as John just
broke down the tune framework T trust
and truth you Unite with love n
neutralize the negative and E elevate
your thinking I was like a fire hose of
value and you know this one of the
greatest occupations I would say of the
content creator knowledge workers being
a knowledge worker means that you need
to tap you need to get out of your brain
outputs you're trying to get creativity
out of your brain out of your heart out
of your spirit and if you're tuned in
the wrong Channel or you're blocked or
you're in a state of discouragement it's
going to be very hard to do your best
work and do your highest level of craft
so man so powerful to use that framework
one of the things I've heard you say as
you were teaching this is that your
certainty needs to be greater than your
doubt can you expand on that yeah
Doubt's always going to come in but your
certainty in why you're here in the work
that you're doing in the impact that you
want to have that has to be greater than
all the negativity and doubt you're
always going to face negativity you're
always going to have critics but guess
what we are here to create we're not
listening to the critics we're not
letting criticism in our head and we're
not letting praise go to our head we're
just here to do the work and we know why
we're here we know the impact we want to
have and we know what we want to build
like what is your vision what is it that
you want to create you first have to
design it before you create it so have
this vision of what you want and once
you have that certainty of what you're
here to build it has to be greater than
all the doubt that you face along on the
way and I meet too many people that give
up or don't have the certainty or don't
have the faith they don't have the trust
and guess what they are more talented
than me they are more talented than a
lot of people out there but they didn't
have the mindset to keep going and
that's why mindset is so essential to be
successful because you have to withstand
all the adversity all the challenges I
have a formula for grit and grit is the
number one predictor and factor of
success and this formula is essential
and it actually begins with it's
inspired by by vision andp purpose it's
fueled by optimism and Faith it's
powered and driven by love and at the
end of the day it's created From the
Inside Out knowing that we always create
from the inside out your soul your
spirit your passion your joy you're
creating from the essence within you
think about it everything we create
appearance is temporary it's temporary
so it's it's on a screen and then it's
off a screen or at some point we're
living this life and that food I eat
that I or I just made it's going to be
eaten we make a great bottle of wine
it's going to be drank but Essence is
eternal Essence is what lasts so the
love that you put into it and the
essence you put into it that's what
lasts so remember the essence that you
actually put into your content that's
what lasts forever this is such powerful
content and I want you to imagine than
media podcast what would happen on the
other side of you tapping into your real
Essence on the other side of you tapping
into another level of Love Of You
neutralizing the negativity of you
elevating your thinking of you tapping
into trust and truth I really believe
that your best content is still in you I
believe that your best days are ahead
and that all of us can benefit from
John's work to put out better content
that doesn't just build our businesses
and build our followings and build our
bank accounts but impacts the world
these types of Frameworks and this types
of content is essential because mindset
really is critical to then taking the
action we need to take or injecting the
content that we're creating with maybe
that lower level of of mindset it's just
not quite getting there what happens
when the videos you're going to make
this week and next week have just
another level of love in them another
level of energy in them another level of
positivity in them John you've added so
much value to us and I know that I think
this is one of the episodes we want to
Rel listen to but I also want to give
you a chance to tell us a little bit
about how we can pick up the one truth
but maybe a few of your other books I
know for me stay positive is one of my
favorites of yours that I like to just
go through to just start the day off the
coffee bean was so powerful for me and I
shared it with our executive team with
Nolan and with Kyle and what I learned
was that sometimes just sing like a
principal they're like okay but I saw
Nolan come to life when I gave him the
illustration it because it's a it's an
analogy it's an illustration it's sticky
it's memorable and now whenever we say
it it sticks with us as a team and so
you have a lot of different things so I
would love for you to shout out some
just different resources maybe that are
top of mind we don't have time to go
through all 28 of your book but we have
some professionals here that have teams
we have some solo creators here some
people that are just starting and may be
feeling a lot of discouragement some
people that want to go to the next level
so tell us a little bit about your work
and we're going to summarize everything
in the show notes and also how people
can follow you yeah I encourage people
to definitely read The Energy Bus I
always say start there the carpenter
will be something that you'll love as a
Creator training camp is all about
Excellence that's my favorite book that
I've written is training camp and then
you know some of the some of the newer
books The Power of Positive leadership
if you lead a team I think that's an
essential book to be a great leader and
we do trainings on that leadership
trainings all around the country we
developed thousands of leaders actually
tens of thousands now around the country
in the world with this model of
leadership it's funny I say positive
leadership but I shouldn't have to say
positive because if you are a leader you
must be positive and optimistic to
create the future and so really
positively it's like organic food like
shouldn't we just call it food why do we
have to say organic food it just should
be food that's a great book power a
positive team if you have a team and you
want them to be a stronger team even a
small creative team I've had a lot of
teams read this book together because
it's the principles of practices that
make great teams great that will be
really helpful as well and then just
Coffee Bean you mentioned my wife and I
wrote a book called relationship grit I
wrote a book called Road the boat with a
football coach named PJ Fleck who
transformed every program he's been in
with his leadership and it's all about
culture so that's been a lot of fun soup
is actually a great book from a
standpoint of U the energy you put into
it determines the quality of it and it's
all about building a culture of
greatness and then more recently that's
coming out or has been out by the time
you watch this is the one truth and I
believe this this is my most important
book and this will help you get to a
higher state of mind that will allow you
to be more creative instead of a lower
state of mind reading this book will
help you connect more to Oneness where
you'll find more creativity power joy
and peace in your creation versus the
negativity that separates you and makes
you feel pessimistic and lowers your
state of mind and I explain it all and I
really take you through how to do this
this is based on my work with all these
professional athletes with artists with
high uh you
High organizational leaders and it's
incredible like the impact it's it's
having that's why I knew I needed to
write this book because these teachings
are transformative and they're like
nothing you've ever heard before that's
what I I love about like talking about
the brain as an antenna helping you
understand how to become one United team
and why a relationship that has
disconnection division leads to mental
health challenges it all makes sense
when you understand this and so that's
why I'm really excited about this book
and you can check it out at get1
truth.com
get1 truth.com and we have a ton of free
resources on there as well as the tune
acronym we have a one sheater on that we
have the whole one sheater as well w h
Ole e which is another action plan and
then we have another action plan on
prayer p r a y r that helps you actually
renew your mind every day and the more
you renew it you transform it and you'll
have more wisdom more ideas coming to
you I gotta tell you we're talking about
creativity and content people it's
amazing how much more creative I've
gotten over the years by doing what I
share in this book and how tuning in
every day makes you more creative I
never take credit for the ideas because
I know they're not for me talk to the
musicians that the jingle just came to
them as they were basically sitting
there and next they next thing you know
they start writing down the music that
came to them there's gifts waiting for
us but if we're always tuning into the
negative you can't hear the voice or
those gifts so you got to be in a state
to receive the gifts and that's what we
talk about in this book how you can
receive the gifts that are meant for you
to be more creative and I'm excited
about how it's going to make you more
creative you know I've never done this
on the thi media podcast before but I do
want to encourage you a lot of times
people are listening when they're on a
commute or doing you know chores of some
kind but I want to encourage you to
revisit this episode so you can dig into
the show notes and yeah I really think
there's two action items here you know
one of the things I did was I went to
Amazon and I purchased about 10 of your
books kind of all at once that's my
style love the physical and I started to
just kind of go through them but we like
to ask the question you know what is the
main thing you need to do next is it a
mindset thing for you is it your team
needs encouragement is it growing as a
leader is it improving your craft when
you've identified kind of perhaps the
the biggest paino or challenge you're
focusing on then the the answer which
one of John's book reveals itself plus
um there's the the one truth website and
all of those things so I want to
encourage you to block some time or even
set a reminder with Alexa or Siri and uh
come back to this episode and just kind
of dig into the show notes I can affirm
and I just want to acknowledge you John
you know from a distance before we ever
got to meet you know we're in the
Wellspring together um your work is so
prolific and is impacted teams and
leaders and made an impact on my life
with like the energy bust and the Power
of Positive leadership but then more
recently as I dug uh deeper and just
kind of re literally ordered I I want to
say I ordered 15 of your books all at
once son like what is happening you know
and I was like that's just I and I love
books I'm probably a a biblio file or
whatever they call them a a biblio
maniac which is where you actually have
an unhealthy obsession with books and it
affects your personal relationships but
in a positive way I would argue um and
so I'm just so grateful for the impact
of your work and and know for sure that
whether it's your your you know weekly
tips on your newsletter or whatever that
we at think media podcast will be better
as we glean from all of these insights
and I can't wait I know that at the time
of recording it hasn't even really hit
the market yet and uh the one truth I'm
so excited to dig into that one and I
think you shared recently even talking
about Romans 12 do not be conformed to
the pattern of this world but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
just thinking about this tune framework
your prayer framework man to get in the
right state every day and to become
better Craftsman and I actually
purchased but I haven't read the
carpenter yet so that one next for me
because I always want to go and uh we're
throwing so much at people but the
Carpenter and the one you mentioned the
training camp because I think media want
our craft our content our craft always
working on Excellence always working on
the next level how can we improve this
podcast how how can we improve our
videos how can I improve um you know as
a speaker as a communicator and so
anyways want to really acknowledge you
and encourage um you listening to this
take some time if you're on the move now
to sit down and maybe plan out we call
it a PDP a personal development plan
plan out what book you're going to read
next give yourself another hour or so to
uh check out some of the resources on
the website that um could take you a
little bit deeper and then allow this
episode and more than that John's
Frameworks to impact your morning
routine even starting tomorrow what what
is your imagine what your future could
look like what your YouTube channel
could look like on the other side of
starting to get into getting tuned into
the one truth and uh going into a whole
another level of your mindset John so
grateful for you and thank you for being
with us on the think media podcast
thanks John I appreciate you and and
thanks for mentioning the books and I
want people to know I want people to
read the books not because I want to buy
a book I want to read it so they can
benefit from it and if they listen to it
if they buy it if they get it to the
library doesn't matter I want you to
benefit from the books and just love
your community I know that they're
creative I know they can get the
discouraged at times and feel dejected
but I think it's awesome that you are
lifting them up and I hope we did that
today so wishing everyone all the best
and just know that I'm rooting for you
and if I can ever encourage you along
the way reach out to me because I do
encourage people and that's my that's my
mission encourage people to keep doing
what they're meant to do and so I think
this was just a perfect thing to be able
to join sea and reaching the community
that you care so much about Sean so I'm
thankful you asked me to do this